the rain forest of northern Peru there
are millions of trees here many rare
plants and animals are at home in this
remote region josé Cruz Theotis takes
visitors on boat tours at this massive
protected habitat he's been doing it for
about a year and a half to supplement
his income he's also a coffee grower
sila this three MOS no knowledge if we
don't protect the rainforest and destroy
it the rains will wash away more and
more soil every day I had to look it is
even want to cut down the trees and
plant coffee ever since the highway was
completed more people have come here
from the coast and from the mountains
cosas de la sierra bastante the highway
connects this remote area to the coast
it's a lifeline for the locals bringing
jobs to the poor region but it has also
spawned migration and a host of new
problems alongside the road there's not
much evidence of the rainforest only
rice and coffee fields the community of
shampoo yakko used to have 4,000
hectares of rainforest now it's less
than 600 the environmental group
International Union for Conservation of
Nature is trying to reclaim some of that
forest project manager Alonso Castro
plants coffee and trees together it lo
que estamos haciendo Nestor woman this
is an attempt to protect the rainforest
and to introduce alternative farming
methods to the coffee growers colas end
of this will allow them to grow higher
quality coffee without destroying more
and more forest land cinco seis de San
Cesario a day for estar mayoral saris
the women of the village are on their
way to the coffee fields they were the
first to become involved in the project
they've started using natural
fertilization which has led to increased
profits when is the project or unfold
this project began the rain forest was
in pretty bad shape we just took
everything we needed knows now we're
giving something back ya no es igual
mucha Stella there was kiss Lysa Arryn
the community leader Thomas wah ha ji to
its loves to show visitors his
greenhouse he's growing both coffee bean
plants and young saplings but I mean
with unit area poco my TV set I see the
poor can tell it was hard to convince
people to plant new trees and to explain
the benefits too young blombo you talked
with everybody and they're taking it
more and more too hard on the planet
coffee and a variety of trees even
banned up those trees provide shade for
the coffee plants especially I meant
this but I saw by jose cruz yacht does
has also planted trees along with coffee
part of the effort to revitalize the
rainforest orita pour cereal turismo it
soon tourism has been a major boon for
the people of this region more and more
visitors are coming all the time even
from overseas Mentos de la gente y los
base bail money yeah that's been a big
boost for the local economy Cena stop
wondering esta so nervous don t but
tourists only go where the rainforests
are intact something Hosea's mindful of
as he prepares the boat for another
group of visitors